نتواجد في احد مراكز اللواء هنا في مخيم
جباليه لنتعايش مع المواطنين اجواء الليل
هنا في هذه المدرسه مع فصل الشتاء كما
نشاهد هنا المواطنين النازحين المتواجدين
هنا في داخل المدرسه يشعلون النار على
الحطب من اجل التدفئه في ظل هذا البرد
السلام عليكم يعطيكم العافيه الحمد لله
على سلامتكم الله يخليكم يا رب والله
اوضاع صعبه يعني نن بنول شويه نار وجمعوا
الناس نا من السقعه و بعمل لهم شويه شاي
شويه هذا طحين فش اكل فش شويه روز بيعملوا
الناس شويه فيش يعني الوضع صعب فوق ما
تتصور على الاخر ما فيش يعني نقول لك
شغلات ما في شيء ميه بتلاقي بع مرات الناس
وضحت صعب لكن صامدين ايشم يسووا ودم
يروحوا نهجر صعب صعب نهجر ل بنموت وتقطع
نا هان وين نروح وروح وين نروح ولا وين
يجي شا
الاطفال مرمين مناظر يعني بتقشعر
البدن مناظر بتقشعر البدن شي يعني لا
يطاق نهائي نهائي نهائي لا يطاق ش بدنا
نسوح ان متوفر الح والله هذا بلمن الشوارع
ودف الناس بنولع انا شوي مطرح القصف
مطرح حبه حطها حبه حاجه ايش هذا لي ليله
زي هيك هذا ولا حاجه كمان شو حزام النار
شغل لكن ولا عبنا بطل ياثر فينا بطل ياثر
ايش
نساوي الناس رم في الشوارع ج في الشوارع
ملانه ملانه و واحد مدور والله احنا يعني
بالرغم من اجواء الحرب و يعني 70 يوم صار
لها الحرب يعني احنا بحاول قدر الامكان
نحاول نقل مع الوضع القائم بنولع شويه نار
بنشرب قهوه بنشرب شاي وبعش عندك الناس
اغلبهم خرجوا من بيوتهم لا
اواعي لا اواعي ولا فراش ولا ما يحزنون
فبج تجمعوا ه كل الحبايب مع
بعض وبيطلع اخونا في النهار ابو محمد طلع
بلمن من الدور المكسوفه شويه خشب بجيبه
شويه ورق من ه ونولع نار زي ما انتم
شايفين يعني هي القصب قبل شوي كان علينا
واحنا صامدين ومش ملحلح وين بدنا نروح
يعني بالرغم انهم قصفوا علينا سو زيتون هي
القاصف على قبالك شايفه وقبل يومين قضيف
تحت وقبل يومين قضيف على الطابق الرابع
والمدرسه اللي حوالينا كمان شهده فيها بس
وين بنا نروح وين بدنا نطلع الناس هنا لا
بتملك اكل لا طحين ولا شرب ولا ما يحزنون
ما فيش اي حاجه الناس مساكين المراه بتجيك
بتقول لك يا عمي انا ما في عندي وهذا ما
في عندي وما في عندي طيب العالم بدها طحين
اليوم بقولوا لي عمي بدي طحين اودي طب انا
من وين اجيب لك طحين ما في شي الشمال
معدوم لا طحين ولا سولار ولا كاز حتى ميه
مفلتره ما فيشي يعني احنا امراض بيجونا
ناس من غزه ققول يا عمي ما في عننا ولا
نقطه مي طب احنا طب ب عننا في بابور في
المدرسه عننا بير طب بدنا نشغله طب بدك
سولار ما فيشي عندك بتجيك مراه بتقول لك
انا في شهر الولاده طب يا عمي من وين طب
اتصل على الاسعاف ما فيش اسعاف كل على
كرات الحمير هذه المدرسه هناك من يبحثون
عن الرزق من اجل الحصول على المال لو
بالشيء
[موسيقى]
البسيط صحن
مهلبيه احد يعني الشبان في هذه المدرسه
يقوم بعمل مهلبيه من اجل بيعها
للاطفال والله فلش الدنيا الواحد فيش ولا
حمات ولا فشات ولا حاجه متوفره نا في
الشمال بدنا نجيب الميه بروح اخر الدنيا
على الموت لما نجيب ال الميه فيش ميه مفن
ولا عاديه العاديه مش ملاق
[موسيقى]
ه ما انت شايف والله كهرب ولا حاجه بشتغل
قاعدين على يدينا محلاتنا
راح هكذا هو المشهد هنا داخل مراكز الاواء
في مخيم جباليه في ظل القصف المستمر
ومعاناه النازحين مع دخول فصل الشتاء انس
الشريف لصالح قناه الجزيره شمال غزه